literal dollar there we go
Christmas
[Music]
Christmas music in my opinion is one of
the most interesting genres chances are
you're listening to Christmas classics
that were made decades ago in fact the
two most modern songs that you'll
probably find on Billboard's Top
Christmas lists are all I want for
Christmas is you buy Mariah Carey and
last Christmas by Wham many artists
don't even bother write original
Christmas songs knowing that they can
make a killing singing the same classics
that everyone already knows so I thought
what's the harm in trying
and while fiddling around with my
ukulele I came up with this I had a
feeling that I was onto something so I
asked my college friend Irene to
co-write the song with me my name is
Irene despite my musical background I
don't feel all too confident in writing
music I'm more of a singer and piano
player I love songwriting but I feel
like I've never tried to challenge
myself but it'd be really cool to try
something different like a Christmas
song even though Irene and I had a lot
of musical talent we needed some help
when it came to writing the song so
we've sought out advice from hit singer
and songwriter scotty grand christmas
songs are really about painting pictures
with their legs when it comes to finding
a great concept though with things that
are universal love getting your heart
broken but you still have to stand out
what haven't you heard them talk about
go there and then bring it home with
something human even though I like a lot
of Christmas songs I don't always relate
to them never had a white Christmas
either so any song that involves snowing
I can't relate to it sorry
that's so sad Irene well I'm from Guam
it's hot there let's definitely go with
that theme like just an unconventional
Christmas song should be simple it can
be repetitive just like Mariah Carey
songs she uses repetition for the chorus
that I have so far it's like doesn't
matter way
when it plays you're right where you
belong so worlds to gifts were given to
put a little Christmas in it put a
little Christmas in it hit Christmas
songs they used seventh chords to use
diminished chords one three five that's
a regular chord now if you go two steps
down that's the seventh chord and these
chords kind of play off the Jazz era of
music where the lyrics were telling more
of a story laughing throughout the town
but you're here trying to find that
Christmas cheer yeah I did something bad
I got so excited about me and Irene
making some progress on the song that I
actually sent an email out to our entire
office saying that we perform it and the
only day that we could do that is three
days away I'm a little worried because
more than half of the song isn't done
yet right now I'm actually talking to a
friend of mine RJ Tolson he's a great
music maker he's going to make us a
track that we can perform lives so I
woke Irene up so I wrote something for
the chorus
[Music]
what do you think I love you we are
stuck up here in this little box we've
got some of the lyrics down so far we
just have to write the second verse and
we'll pretty much good read I meant
practice at a million times so this is
how many lines that we're probably gonna
need for it see you something something
something so basically this is how many
spots mean to fill before we get to the
chorus first two needs to be more about
the things you do to get in the
Christmas spirit I wrote it won't matter
where you are whether home is near or
far are the tanks is just a memory of
the time when you were all it takes
some memory from the time you yeah and
just need two more lines no we need to
stop using the word feel let me we don't
use it that much yeah we do
[Music]
Oh what are you going to do to get
yourself back to this place when you
really you're gonna play your
[ __ ] favorite Christmas huh but
I don't know how to get back
if you hold close and don't let go you
can feel it start to grow if you home
too close and don't let go you can feel
it in in your soul and you hold close
and don't let go you can feel it and you
so if you just perfect
you think we're gonna do okay we'll see
the next main thing is just not being
nervous and performing it with confident
I'm gonna be sad if they don't like the
song or if they don't feel it who gives
a [ __ ] what they think we made a great
song so whatever right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
how do you call this Christmas you can
barely feel the cold you miles from
everyone yellow the place never snows
and you can own weight under the
mistletoe where'd it go
you see people all around singing
laughing through the town but you're
here trying to find that Christmas cheer
and burr wondering what to do just to
get
Christmas moon
[Music]
they favorite Christmas song baby does
it matter if no body sings along just a
little spirit and you make things bright
this life it's a gift forgiven so put a
little Christmas in it you can feel that
Christmas spirit
like there's something in the app it
don't matter where you are where their
home is their far all it takes is just a
memory from a time when you were young
if you hold it close and don't let go
you can feel it in your soul if you die
favorite Christmas song baby does it
matter if no sings alone just a little
spirit and you make things bright this
life it's a gift forgiven so put a
little Christmas in your favorite
Christmas
[Music]
it's a gift worth giving so put a little
baby does it matter if no Bonnie sings
alone just a little spirit and you make
things right this life it's a gift for
giving so put a little Christmas info
put a little Christmas in it Oh put a
little Christmas in it Oh Christmas in
it put a little Christmas city
[Music]
that was incredible and I identified it
with the song greatly because none of my
family lives in California they all live
in the Midwest okay I thought this was
like a Jason Mraz like song even if you
don't celebrate Christmas you kind of
celebrate the season and the vibe I like
that that tagline is put some Christmas
in itself but some Christmas in it this
is about you know making new traditions
and new memories and I think the song
showcases that a lot when is it coming
out on iTunes I'll buy it legally when
we started writing this I didn't really
know if we could do it but then to
actually perform it in front of people
was oh my god it was mind-blowing this
was an original song that no one had
ever heard before when you're writing an
original it's putting puzzle pieces
together but you don't know what the
puzzles supposed to look like I think
because we really believed in what we
were writing we were able to make
something really special this really
shows you that whatever artistically you
feel like you want to express or do you
can do it you could write the next all I
want for Christmas is you it's still a
challenge but you'll be surprised at
like what you're actually capable of
doing once you set your mind to
something Merry Christmas but a little
Christmas City
[Music]